foreign
you're famous in Germany John Tick Tock
has 7.6 million views it's like a
million views a move to Berlin and work
with me I can make you a star I'm moving
to Germany baby
I'm a new star is here nice to meet you
bumper Heidi is amazing should be your
assistant too
[Music]
it's like the Fourth of July meets a
Super Bowl halftime show except that we
are way cooler about showing nipples
here
bumper Ellen's going to try to play at
Unity day it doesn't have the range I
can go from YouTube
I just think that
yeah you know so I'm amazing the proper
performance is hard even for the most
seasoned performers don't worry and
we're better under pressure what's up
Berlin
[Applause]
nope nope
[Music]
I've wanted to be famous my entire life
I thought Berlin was going to change
everything
[Music]
if you don't take a risk you don't grow
somebody get the match because bomba's
song is a bang what if we turn this into
a rhythm Americans you are obsessed with
your whip off Riff Off whiff off Riff
Off you said wave of acid refer okay
[Music]
you don't know my
[Music]
name
[Applause]
I'm not like a corny acapella guy I'm
cool right
right
[Music]